et bien bonjour les amis et bienvenue à
jean un peu loin salut maxime amics m
il a aimé ça mais c'est ce qu'on a fait
aujourd'hui on va composer une musique
en une heure c'est faux tu veux partir
pour la balle allait bientôt mais celle
ci n'a pas du tout parlé de ce bureau en
fait
ah oui c'est vrai on a volé le bureau de
mcfly carlito rit parce que le mien
était trop bas bref c'est un jeu pour
enfants de 7 ans et demi appuyez sur ce
bouton est que ces gens doit faire des
petits à coup et quand il va bien vite
il va falloir le lâcher ils atterrissent
correctement là bas on est sur un but
voilà là par exemple j'ai raté des
classes nous réussit à faire un salto et
et à le voir atterrir comme ça oui oui
comme ça
ou comme sa lecture est licite a le
droit de faire un tweet avec mon compte
twitter
okc j'ai réussi j'ai le droit de faire
tout est très bien somme c'est comme ce
que mc fly to avec les gymnastes twitter
jeunes aux hymnes au talkie challenge
twitter copé ne se passe rien peut faire
tourner à voir si cette aura
au dommage c'est le voilà on va passer
des heures sur sable je te vois ce que
les gars j'ai testé j'arrivais pas c'est
un secret très court à aucun moment une
envie de poser sa fille sur le tapis
mais le premier qui va poser cet hymne
américain
mais je trouvais ça beau très beau y
avait de l'ergonomie mais ça mais c'est
mieux mexes a été beau c'est sûr qu'on
va pouvoir enquêter dans cette vidéo wii
ce cadre non non seulement d'un soutien
mais j'avais huit mille fois sur ce
bouton là mais qu'on va faire aucun
tweet c'est quand même le truc des
boutons aliou faye toute ma vie j'ai
envie d'offrir à tous et tous pour ces
trois essais chacun sait
[Musique]
trois essais on a dit trois essais
fauchés parce que là j'en ai marre
hockey à s'amuser parce que là ils sont
censés faire des points est encore petit
ya des points selon la distance à
laquelle tu veux avec je serai sur une
fois c'est incroyable
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
romero
[Musique]
qu'est ce que c'est mérité
tiens je t'ai film on compte youtube
mois touche attendant je vais tout mais
je crois que j'ai trouvé que moi je
crois aussi oui mais attention quand
même
ouais je mets pas un truc
[Musique]
elle a été longue à terme la chaîne abc
en scène ses guerriers sacré mcfly
c'est michael caine et au kayak à celui
là encore un défi à mâcon ça pue le proc
ah je sais pas quel jumelles a perdu
visiblement savait mais que c'est dur de
me rattraper
non je ne sais pas avec mal faille
qualité wells et aurait pu gérer
simplement envie d'exprimer mon opinion
politique
non par contre 3,7 à vue c'est comme ces
miniatures minimes et des flèches rouges
j'ai fait la même par contre on peut
changer de 10,9 à ces la peau du monde
avait quand même faire inviter à ce
genre de jeu je prends rencontres
nationales et consentants commandes
voilà voilà voilà quelle vitesse quelle
rapidité d'exécution et pourtant rien à
l'est
[Musique]
quel dommage ça donne une impulsion
footeux plaisir sur les mares de tout
cela on passe un très bon moment ça nous
touche beaucoup et tout compris
d'ailleurs été abonnés qu'ils disent
carnet quel bon gastina avons bien fait
il a choisi le bon jeu et les bons
guette c'est nickel on est tous de ce
mot est parfait voilà pas c'est
peut-être mon regard weight avec mme
trotter à toulouse je peux le faire
toujours de toi moi même toujours la
même
c'est après 202 je peux jouer contre moi
même ok quand est ce que tu attends tu
es ce que tu as puis à quel moment au a
bien joué mais tu m'as vu tu fais un
tweet jeter l'homme j'espère que ça ne
te faire du bien droit
à bien jouer rien j'avoue merde mais
qu'est ce qu'on a fait mais tu ramasses
est ce que après avoir fait cette vidéo
tu vas acheter le jeune société ben oui
je vais clairement acheter un docteur
d'imboulou en vidéo comme le monde
[Musique]
attends attends tu vois une photo
tu vas conseillé à mal dans ma vie je
regardais cette photo il vous
souviendrez j'vais franchement tu as
connu pire handicap tacconi fils à la
deuxième tweet pour toi tu es de
queyries 78 10 sport et mme p et pour
une vidéo ensemble veste et cravate et
insolent
ah oui le sentiment est en face à la
caméra sur le 100 points mais que la c1
tout ça alors je veux juste voir les
réponses vite fait de ce que les gens
tombent et huawei et nous avons dû
[Musique]
28 non vraiment j'insiste 30 minutes
comme ça et tu as eu le temps de faire
un plat je trouve très honnêtement je
suis youtuber qui fait les meilleures
vidéos de la plateforme ses tweets est
alors c'est quoi bon enfin de bol c'est
fou moi j'ai un désavantage
je dois le faire à l'envers c'est super
chiant pardon pour toi 3 [ __ ] ça mal
fait un coup tu d'en bas bon oui c'était
ma vraie partie aux coûts ainsi que j'ai
vraiment mal timmins des bouquins de jeu
il y en a plus un nouveau one mais la
vidéo alexis moerenhout en mai aps le
droit que ça s'envoie des grosses photos
de villars-sous-écot hasard si ma maison
c'est mal et juste envoyer un petit mec
tu abuses à votre cas c'est quoi je vais
me chercher des sandwiches mais pour
faire chez moi je fais un peu moins
qu'il n'y avait pas de son maillot qui
agace du jambon beurre et du coup la
merci des fallas adresse mail à la
personne
3 on a le son va la preuve plus calmes
amener un sandwich j'appuie sur le
bouton j'ai fais ça tu as fait une vidéo
où tu as dit que tu ferais que des
vidéos qui te plaît sinon pas comme ça
la n est dupe il est traité j'ai changé
d'avis hall à partir de demain une vidéo
par jour
elles sont regardés réponse un tp aux
tweets attend quoi au oui j'ai créé le
doute a créé une embrouille rtg2 ferme
ta grosse galles km/h et attaques
ennemies génie dès le prochain qui
réussit il doit faire un périscope où il
fait semblant de pleurer d'être mal je
serai bien que c'est moi qui ai sur le
live
[Rires]
aux attentes futures il aider vous je
peux le faire comme toi
à les entendre
alex
[Musique]
j'y arrive ouais mais tu y arrives pas
nick tuer la vidéo gag acheter des
sandwichs tel mandat du mal berne - m
haies et que je me prendre en photo moi
quand j'irai pas bien ressortir à cette
photo il me disait je dirais tant achim
et a fini par y arriver
ce qu'on peut parler des auréoles alors
j'en ai par les banques n'étaient pas là
mais que j'ai tellement chaud à forte de
par ce juge les auréoles les ponts 6
hectares on a tous rigolé les gens en
ont parlé parlé je leur parle pas
toujours pas parlé comme ça
[Musique]
fatigué un peu vrai ça a pas de ouf je
vous avoue ça pas de ouf je suis pas
très j'ai pas très chaud aujourd'hui
merci pour les coeurs c'est gentil what
happens bas ces chevaux je suis pas j'en
ai marre j'en vis un peu de tout arrêter
voilà non je suis juste pas très en fin
de jeu souley gérer que tu as pleuré
non mais ça va je t'ai jamais un gage
pouvait faire ça c'était ignoble désolé
tout va bien on fait avec nos moyens
il y en a plus d'un qui croyais je suis
désolé pour les apprentis pilotes
n'étaient pas à lui mais si elle vous a
plu ça m'a brisé le coeur les gens je
les voyais les et sarah pas qu'est ce
que tu as tu as pleuré
merci avec celle d'avoir les ir 26
novembre vite et j'ai choisi endurait
prochaine fois je faisais comme abou
l'unocam à bientôt les gens super scope
et puis à un gros bisou t'en vas nous
entendons des coups ce temps tout était
si jamais on est jours d'escale à
bientôt les gens sont payés scop
et puis un gros bisou
[Musique]